[Musique]
accueilli par le maître des lieux les
visiteurs sont instantanément transporté
au milieu du 19e siècle
à cette époque la maison fournaise est
le lieu de prédilection des peintres
impressionnistes
à l'occasion du centenaire de la mort
d'auguste renoir le musée propose une
expérience immersive
comme il est extrêmement difficile de
pouvoir présenter des tableaux de renoir
qui sont conservés aujourd'hui dans le
monde entier
l'idée était de raconter son histoire
ici à chatou lorsqu'il avait deux autour
d'une trentaine d'années et jusqu'à ce
qu'il prenne ce déjeuner des canotiers
auguste renoir a passé une douzaine
d'années à chatou et c'est ici même sur
l'île des impressionnistes qu'il a peint
le célèbre tableau des écrans numériques
des tablettes ou des casques de réalité
virtuelle permettent d'entrer au coeur
de la peinture de l'artiste
dès l'entrée on propose au visiteur via
un écran tactile de s'amuser entre
guillemets avec les tableaux de renoir
et de l'hérault composé donc on choisit
un tableau et on a différents objets
qu'on va finir pouvoir insérer dans le
tableau les modifier les agrandir les
tournées 18 mois de travaux ont été
nécessaires pour imaginer cette
expérience numérique qui se veut aussi
ludique qu'enrichissante
[Musique]
oh